- So, speaking of kiddos
though, you just announced
that you and your girlfriend,
you're having a baby, right?
Congrats.
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
- Are you... I mean, here's the thing,
I have a six and eight year old.
- Me and my fiance, yes.
- Yeah, your fiance? Oh, congratulations.
I'm so sorry, I thought it was girlfriend.
Next level. Okay.
- Yes, next level. Indeed.
- [Kelly] I like it.
- Yes. We're expecting another baby.
- [Kelly] A little baby?
- Yes.
- So, okay.
So what are you most excited
about a new little baby?
I love the smell.
- Well, that's a hard
question because of the...
(audience chuckling)
- And then the skin on
skin, but go ahead, you go.
- But I can't, I, when you
ask me that, I can't...
The first thing I do, I'm drawn to,
you know, speak about,
it's the lack of sleep.
- Yeah, no. Okay. That
was my next question.
What are you most not excited about?
- Right. That.
- [Kelly] Yeah. You don't get sleep, yeah.
- You don't get any sleep at all.
And, but I'm really excited about
really creating a foundation
which he could leverage himself
you know, growing up.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's important.
(audience applauding)
- I think it's cool too.
Like, I have friends that
have kids of all ages, right?
And they have had them at
different points in life
and I had kids later in life
compared to where I'm from.
They all like, have babies
right outta high school
usually where I'm from.
- Me too.
- [Kelly] So, yeah.
So it's like, so I was
late, I was in my thirties.
So, I love that I was older.
I felt like I had a different mindset
and I felt like I was more
responsible, more selfless,
all those things that-
- Mature, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, more mature.
So do you feel like it's
kind of a different,
a different time to have a kid, right?
So it's like, it's like, I don't know.
I feel like it's-
- It's a great time for me.
- [Kelly] Later in life,
I feel like it's better.
- Yeah. It's, it's very much so.
I think, you know, for men in general,
you need to at least
be 35, 40 to, you know.
- Yeah, spread the word.
- Because really.
We're not much of a man until we've,
you know, achieve, you know,
some of the challenges that,
you know, young men would face, you know?
We're, we're not much of a man. And so-
- But I Think women too, it's
better later in life, I think.
- And women too. It's a little bit better.
- You get experience life in your twenties
and really know what you're talking about.
- You get to experience,
you get to travel.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yes. Absolutely.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I'm excited
for y'all. That's exciting.
Well we heard, so we
got you a little gift.
So this is for...
(audience applauding)
- Oh, sweet. Thank you.
- So there's a little onesie.
- Yes. Yes.
- And it says "Their life
would suck without you."
That's right, that's what we did.
Yep, yep, yep.
And then that's to keep
your little one warm.
- Right.
- And a bunny.
But then this is to
keep you warm and happy.
- To keep my, yes.
- Yeah, that's Kosta Browne.
That's a real good wine.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] You're welcome in advance.
- Absolutely. Thank you.
- You're gonna use that at night.
(Kelly laughing)
When you're not sleeping.
- I'm, I'm using it right away.
- [Kelly] I know. I love wine.